going back to the tour i'm wondering
like
did you find that there was like
different crowd energy in like the
different places that you went and you
had to like kind of tailor your
performance to where wherever you were
or like the energy that you felt yeah i
mean that's why i was saying how like
you can tell americans are just far more
boisterous about things right for a life
scenario that's [ __ ] amazing because
they will cheer you on to everything
they're so much like more energetic and
they're just so much more maybe they're
more attuned to live culture or
something i don't know yeah yeah yeah um
or maybe you're just loud but it's great
it made me feel awesome
um but then going to europe it was very
different because there's like some
jokes that are kind of like
like about ireland and like like being a
catholic boy and go being an altar boy
in church and things like that and i
think americans relate to irish people
very much considering they all tell me
they're irish
but don't know any places from there
yeah
you're in boston and um everyone's irish
yeah yeah
but um places like france and germany
like there was language barriers and
stuff and like irish humor didn't really
play as easily people were so fun and
they had energy and they were still
energetic about it but some places laugh
right with others and then
having a joke about like i had a joke
about being an altar boy and then i was
saying like teenage years got dark or
whatever and it was like a joke about
basically hinting at like priest versus
altar boy culture right right but not
saying anything about it obviously just
letting the audience like make that
interpretation and then i was like no
not that kind of show
and people would laugh but salt lake
city did not
it's like mormon mecca yeah
all the mormons like go and like big
churches right there and they were kind
of like
they're like don't like that one
do people like come up to you after the
show for example and like you know be
like oh hey you know i really liked your
show but like this joke was kind of
weird or you know because you hear about
like comedians doing that right like
after the show they'd like go into the
crowd and be like meet the fans or like
you know it turns out it's really easy
when you're not transphobic
if you're not saying racist [ __ ]
transphobic [ __ ] homophobic [ __ ] it's
real easy to like put on a show without
those jokes in there what a hot day
only the hottest steaks here on trash
tastes not to punch down on you yeah
yeah yeah yeah wow um but yeah i mean my
my jokes never really went that far a
lot of stuff is about my life and my
experience through it so it's like
luckily you weren't a transparent racist
yeah yeah yeah yeah life's much better
when you're not though
when a joke doesn't land does it is does
it like cause like i can't i can't i can
imagine it like in like a twitch
scenario i can't imagine it in a live
scenario where you're just like this
joke's gonna land it's just like if you
say a joke on twitch right the worst
thing you'll have is someone in the chat
being like that wasn't funny yeah but
when they're in front of you
i'm sure it hurts a lot more right yeah
there's been a couple of times where
like i have a big punch line and there's
like one joke near the end of the show
that even now
like i just didn't know how to get the
punch line across right right and i
would say it and then people laughed at
the thing before it a little louder
because oh that's not the punch line
like do i move on from this now i'm like
right off there or do i but i'm i'm a
[ __ ] for a laugh i'll just
i'll keep hammering it until someone
laughs and then if it's really cringey
you just lean into that and be like
takers oh okay yeah i thought we were
here for a comedy show but i guess not
and then the show in london i did it at
the troxie theater um and it i don't
know why i said that no one [ __ ]
knows what that is but i uh yes
i i did it there and the projector broke
so the hdmi connection didn't work so
when i had to have the game on screen it
didn't show up so i had to like vamp for
a bit and like
build up the crowd and like bake it into
the show
right people said it was funny and i'm
like you got a more unique experience i
guess out of it yeah so sometimes the
cringe kind of like helps but there's
definitely times where i'm like drowning
on stage and i'm like
please just now i don't have enough
material
that makes me feel good that at least i
have these two to rely on
like i don't think i could ever do like
a solo like stage show like yeah if we
drown we drown together
with enough prep you'd be able to do it
right i think i think any of you would
be able to i hope so
maybe two cups
but
this time around at least it'll just be
us three we we we've got each other's
backs yeah what are you guys going to do
in the show
um
that's a really good question well i
mean like i'm starting thinking about it
i mean without spoiling any of the ideas
that we have right now i like the
general idea is to bring the trash taste
experience which we're famous for just
on stage because basically what you're
experiencing right now sean we want to
we want to give the audience a little
bit of a taste of basically you know
being on the show being part of the show
kind of right you know
hopefully yeah but hopefully yeah
yeah it's tangents maybe yeah yeah see
how it goes it'll be more structured
than one of our episodes but it'll be
like you know the highlights of why you
like the trash taste show and everything
just brought on stage so you have your
own running jokes that you can bring
back
do we have our own running many yeah
bring people up on stage that's always a
crowd pleaser as well and that's always
so scary though like that yeah because
it's like what if you accidentally bring
the wrong kind of person oh yeah that
has i'm sure that's happening it
happened in iowa where it's like i
brought people up and being like do you
have a youtube name because it's like if
you're gonna sit in the chair and like
do the thing if you have a youtube now
is the time to shout it out right yeah
people here will go home and watch you
if you're good at this but then it was a
chance for people to make up their own
name and then i would make up like titty
sprinkles and things like that right but
then one guy got up and said that he was
our word giraffe
and i was like
and the crowd cheered and i was like
okay i'm like nah you've got a different
name
i kind of just had to like cut it off
and like move on immediately but you
don't want to bum the crowd out and like
punish the person on stage yeah yeah
yeah exactly but at the same time it's
kind of weird to be like all right thank
you our word gerard
it was a round of applause
for our giraffe yeah it was it was tough
yeah oh my god
yeah i guess i guess that just comes
with experience then that like hearing
your stories that scares me but it also
makes me excited it sounds like a very
very fun experience i mean i think
everyone there
kind of because you're not like
professional comedians you're not like
john mulaney getting upset yeah yeah
people expect them to handle it better
right and like right and stuff because
i've been doing it for years and there's
like a formula to it but i think yeah
with
our type of content i think people are
far more forgiving yeah if you kind of
like stall on stage and people are like
i wouldn't know how to deal with that
yeah but like i also think like a lot of
youtubers we started off you know we
started off doing youtube videos because
we were not good at maybe like speaking
in front of like a public audience or
maybe that's just how we were as a kid
you know we never thought that we'd be
like standing up on stage in a panel
yeah and like you know public speaking
basically yeah and so it's just it's
been sometimes it's a real learning
curve to be like maybe this this is
actually really fun and it's a skill
that you develop in your career which
you never thought you would
yes
i think the secret to me for live shows
was to not be afraid of the audience
right because there's a tendency that
there's so many more of them and now
they're here and they demand a good show
because they're paying for it yeah yeah
yeah if they started heckling or
anything i would just like [ __ ] on them
immediately all right it's not a [ __ ]
classroom like you don't have all the
answers
and like bake that into the show and
then they're kind of like okay i'll be
quiet
or someone gets up and says the wrong
thing then you just hand them the mic
and be like okay good luck like you
handle the [ __ ] crowd
there's a there's a bunch of little
things like that and i think getting
over that fear of like the audience
can't like destroy me while i'm up here
yeah i should take that should have
taken notes yeah right if only there was
some other way you could look like
i don't watch my own shows